Sunday nights at 8:00 starting December
1st on up wave on HLN author light
packer human guinea pig welcome to the
Tim Ferriss experiments get ready to
hack your life discover your highest
potential at embarrass experiment coming
this December up wave on HLN
best-selling author Tim Ferriss tackles
seemingly impossible challenges and
offers life lessons
check out the Tim Ferriss experiment
Sunday December 1st at 8 p.m. on up wave
on the HLN Network and check out the
premiere of the link below right now
so this is a review of the Disney film
frozen not the 2010 film or Iceman and
his two buddies get stuck on a ski lift
not that one
[Music]
frozen is about two sisters one of them
has magic powers she can touch things
and turn them into ice she has a hard
time controlling it a lot of people
don't like it there's two dudes one of
them is a prince together is an ice
salesman there's a talking snowman and
everybody sings a lot
it's a classic Disney stuff so these two
sisters they grew up together in this
castle their parents were king and queen
as I said one of these girls has ice
powers she can create anything she wants
to into snow or ice or whatever and when
that becomes a problem the relationship
for these two sisters become strained
and they grow farther and farther apart
until it becomes such an issue that the
entire kingdom is at stake and then to
figure out a way to save each other and
find each other and there's man and love
and romance and singing and all that
good stuff no I had heard a lot of
things about frozen going into it I
heard that it was one of the new Disney
classics that people would really enjoy
this movie but it's the perfect type of
Disney movie like it revisits Disney's
roots that a lot of people were very
excited about that and that is true
frozen is a pretty fun movie a very
beautifully animated movie this movie
has terrific 3d animation the 3d is
gorgeous there's a lot of things that
pop out of you but it doesn't feel like
it's a gimmick it actually feels as if
it's incorporated into the story
which is the best way to do 3d is to not
be like hey here's all this stuff oh boy
you're like cool I guess where's that to
do with anything they're able to
incorporate the 3d into the story and
that's one of the reasons why it worked
because it wasn't just really well done
on a technical level it actually worked
for the store which is cool you know as
I said this is one of those movies where
characters sing a lot I notice be
sitting down like hello how are you
doing today la dee da da da
I'm a girl I like Philly romantic things
and horses and normally I'm not a big
fan of that like it does kind of get on
my nerves sometimes where characters
randomly break out and song not here
though didn't bother me why is that the
songs were actually good the film was
directed so well that I actually was
getting into some of the musical
elements of it but there was a point in
this movie where it went from being
pretty fun to actually pretty good and
that's where this character named Olaf
appears he's completely oblivious to his
environment he doesn't understand the
whole fire and melting snow thing he's
he's very curious about spring and
summer and everyone's like should we
really talk to him about that because
probably not a good time for snowmen to
be around there are certain times in
movies where you get to that point where
that side character is suddenly
introduced it's supposed to be the comic
relief and you're like wow I hate that
guy like Jar Jar Binks for instance
you're watching Star Wars Phantom Menace
Jar Jar Binks come in and you're like oh
that's a cool looking guy he's annoying
as hell I hate him
and he needs to die now Olaf came in and
I was like this could ruin the mood oh
he's awesome like he was just great such
a great character he made the movie way
better than it could have been and one
of the things about Disney movies like
this is the whole Disney
damsel-in-distress cliche is getting
very tired like oh the girl needs saved
every two seconds
oh she's so sickly and pale and helped
me and huh like this movie has that in
there but without spoiling anything it
has a great way of subverting it that I
thought really improved the movie
because I'm getting sick of that whole
cliche the whole the girl always needs
to be saved by the big strong man cuz
look I don't have any problem with that
it's fun to watch a hero be a hero but
after a while it's like yeah okay the
girl is you know you're capable of
fighting it's cool I try to do that with
brave and it started out that way but
then it became like a mother-daughter
story and I was like can't she just be a
fighting badass why does it have to turn
into a mother-daughter story all of a
sudden like I wanted to see more of her
being a fighting badass cuz she was
that's a side brand this movie has
Disney classic written all over it kids
will love this movie especially girls
even more especially sisters like
they're gonna poop they'll poop like
it's perfect like if you have daughters
you know and and maybe
fighting right now and and they just
they're not really getting along that
well
take them to frozen because it'll just
it'll just as for negatives to the film
I thought that there were some really
great action scenes in this movie but
not quite enough of him like there were
scenes where she tries to use her powers
and you're like yes yes this is really
cool but the thing is that her parents
taught her to withhold them and not
share them with the world so you don't
get as much of that and what it does
actually come to the point where she
starts to use her powers mara was like
yes I want more of this but there wasn't
really enough of that intensity because
I thought that was a really cool story
element that wasn't really exploited as
well as it could have been the romance
in the film was cute but not really
involving at all and yes it is a Disney
film so adults probably won't feel very
into the romance kids will like it
adults will kind of smile at it but I
wish the romance was more than just your
Disney kind of winking cute eNOS for the
standards of this film I think it did a
really good job for what it's trying to
be yeah I'm probably not gonna ever pop
it in and watch it again but for what it
is and for its age demographic and
audience it's really going to hit home
and it is a clever film and it is very
well made so for that reason I got to
give it a B+ so guys when you see the
film tell me what you thought of it and
what is your favorite Disney film that
involves singing that's probably the
Lion King I mean it's definitely Lion
King as always guys thanks very much for
watching and if you liked this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]